you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create
amazing actual relationships ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show an expert on your career
and your job and boy is that a subject
out there today we're here to talk to
you about your life and your money the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're gonna
start with baltimore this hour robin is
there hi robin how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
thank you for taking my call um my
question today is my husband and i own a
home
and we're looking to we're hoping to
move soon but we also have some debt um
so we're just trying to figure out the
best next steps um
for
for ourselves
okay why are you moving
um we need more space we have a two
bedroom and we have an 18 month old fun
and we would like to try for another
baby uh soon cool we would like to have
a three bedroom house and i also work
from home so we do need like some type
of office space or area okay how much
data have you got not counting your
house
not counting the house i would say
70 or 50 in
student loans and i'm sorry 55 in
student loans at 15 and credit cards
okay
and um
what's your household income
95 000. good for you okay what do you
guys do for a living
i am a financial analyst and my husband
works in auto manufacturing okay all
right
well your goal
of moving up in-house to have you know a
little more room for your family is a
great goal
and it's a reasonable goal
i think we can agree it is a want
and not a need
okay i would say like we could get to a
need is shelter
you have shelter
you have one baby and a two-bedroom
house
everything's okay today
but it'd be nice to move up it'd be nice
to move up i'm not saying you can't do a
one i spend money on once i'm okay with
that but we need to classify it where it
really is now the number one
key to building wealth the number one
wealth building tool that you have is
your income and when you send it all to
sally may
it's very difficult to build wealth
and so
before you buy once
you get your
house in order
no pun intended um and uh that means you
get these debts paid off
and so if i'm you i'm rolling up my
sleeves i'm going to work as much as i
can work i'm going to live on nothing
and i'm going to knock out these debts
asap
and um it's probably going to take you
18 months and that's living on beans and
rice
18 months so you suggesting in the house
for now stay in the house
and get out of debt
before you spend money on luxuries which
is a move up in house is a luxury
your family is not going to die if you
don't move up in-house it would just be
a really nice thing to get to move up
in-house that means it's a luxury not a
need
yeah it would just be uncomfortable
and i guess a lot of people cut expenses
but like daycare is so expensive we pay
um when we pay
1300 a month and daycare is more than
ours your option is to move up in-house
and keep the debt and you will be stuck
in the middle class the rest of your
life because you're not dealing with
your issues
i want you to become wealthy
i need you
when you move up in-house you're going
to move up in-house payment now your
budget's going to be even tighter
because sally mae also needs her own
bedroom
yeah so robin you do make a very good
point you can cut expenses
so what can we do to reduce the child
care costs got to look at it from 18
different angles where there's a will
there's a way is an old phrase and in
this case yes thirteen hundred dollars a
month for child care uh that's a lot and
it's more than your mortgage you said so
i would absolutely be doing what dave
said but finding ways to make more money
and reduce costs which means you could
take that 18 months as dave saying with
rice and beans and with more income we
add the more intensity we add the
quicker you get out of this
debt and now we can begin to think about
the future but your focus needs to be on
the now thanks robin we appreciate your
call
so guys i talked to our staff here our
1200 team members monday morning and um
we talked about a little bit on the air
the other day but it's what bears are
repeating ken that
um
here's what i'm always going to give you
i'm always going to give you the hard
path on the short term
because it is the easy path in the long
term
i'm never going to give you the easy
path in the short term because it's
always the hard path in the long term
easy path for her in the short term is
go buy a nicer house
but she's stuck in the debt her budget's
even tighter she's going to struggle to
be able to build wealth and find money
to save and invest for her kids college
and for their retirement investing and
be able to get the house paid off and
sally may kicked out and the other rest
of that debt kicked out that's what
normal people do they buy whatever they
want whenever they want it like they're
in congress
and normal
normal finances in america suck you
don't want to be normal
it's awful
and so what you want to be is unusual
you want to be weird so one of the
greatest compliments you get on the show
is if i call you weird
means you're being you're doing hard
stuff to get an easy life long term
it's always harder
to work out and avoid a doughnut
than it is to just pop donuts in your
face believe me i know
i have the ability to eat untold
infinite numbers of donuts in one
setting
uh and i have to curb that appetite but
and it's hard
but it's easier than walking around with
all the diseases of obesity right
well you know the minds this is a
mindset so
a lot of people think of
this type of rice and beans gazelle
intensity that dave that we teach as a
sacrifice and i think it's worth
shifting that mindset from thinking of
it as a sacrifice and think of it as an
investment it's a price to be paid yes
yes i am investing in my life admission
to a better life that's it and you've
got to invest in yourself so stop
thinking of oh it's drudgery and oh we
got a sacrifice and all we got is you
know okay here's if we do this
this has yield long-term yield long-term
impact long-term return on my investment
not my sacrifice but i'm investing in me
my family our future yeah like a buddy
of mine there was a huge negative
article written about me a buddy of mine
goes like oh man i'm i'm so sorry and i
said well you know it's the price of a
mission to get to be dave ramsey
i'll pay the price it's awesome i don't
want to be somebody else i like me
life's good i got a great life and if
all that means is some idiot left-wing
journalist thinks i'm a capitalist pig
and correctly identified me as such um
then uh then have at it baby that's the
price of admission to be dave that's
right you know what's the price of
admission to be wealthy what's the price
of a mission to raise great kids what's
the price of admission to look at your
drunk friend and say you need to get off
the sauce you're screwing up your life
it's harder to have the conflict than it
is go along and buy him another round
hard
is easier
than easy
always turns out to be hard
because you're wimping you're mailing it
in
you're not paying a price
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today bailey's in colorado
springs hey bailey how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
awesome thank you guys for taking my
call um so my question has to do it's
job related so back in march i took a
job as a wine and liquor sales rep it's
100 commission and it's exactly what
i've wanted to do for years now
i work for a very small company out of
denver and so i'm selling just smaller
brand names and
and i've been taking your advice and
trying to keep as many doors open as
possible
so i have been trying to
ask reps their names and so on and i ran
into what i thought was a rep last week
and he was actually a district manager
filling in for a rep that had currently
quit he works for a company that i've
been a bigger company that i've been
told would be a very good company to
work for
so my question is still 100 commission
i just uh
they're i'm going through the interview
process and they sound like they want me
to join their team
i just don't know i really like the
small company that i work for
but i also would like to help my family
succeed financially we're debt free um
so on the high end with this current
position that i have i'm probably making
gonna make close to fifty thousand
dollars if i really hustle and grind it
um and then this new job i'd probably be
close to seventy thousand with just
commissions alone on the low end
so i'm just kind of
yeah
so
what i heard is that there's a feel
there's a comfort level with this
smaller company so let's dive deeper
into this let's just assume and we can't
assume that you're going to get the job
okay that they're going to offer but it
sounds good but let's just assume that
right now we have both in front of us
all right
what is
the biggest fear there's some fear here
what is the fear about taking the new
job if it was presented what are you
afraid of
um i've worked for bigger companies
before um i know they're more corporate
i think that's what scares me
is
i like what i'm so with the job that i'm
with right now
it's i like the flexibility with it
which there's flexibility with this new
one as well but i like that
it's almost as if i'm running my own
business and i don't
um it just it feels like i'm running my
own business which is something that i
really
enjoyed that was hard is just the
the commission like last month was a
really tough month uh commission wise
because i also had to you know if i'm
not working i'm not making money so and
i had to take two weeks left so bailey
hear here's what i hear you don't have a
really good
clear fear to define and that's part of
what is causing the fear is you don't
really know
if it's going to be that much different
anybody who is straight commission in in
all reality does run their own business
so i don't think there's that big of a
deal so here's what i want you to do i
want you to continue to walk this out go
through all the interviews let's get it
all the way
to the point they make the offer i would
start today beginning to ask questions
where it's appropriate in the interview
process
on around the issue of what is it like
the autonomy what are the what's the
hours what's the accountability what's
the what's the reporting process the
sales process you don't ask it the way
that i'm saying that but you're diving
into those issues because there is a
comfort level with the way you sell for
this current company so get on a piece
of paper get it out of your head and
write down this is what i like about
this sales position that i'm currently
in these are the characteristics and so
you ask questions that will allow you to
get answers to determine wait a second
it's a bigger company yes more corporate
but it's largely the same it's what i
kill is what i eat and i think you just
dive into that ask about culture
questions how do we grow what's the
measurement process what's the
development process and training process
ask lots of questions which is normal to
do in the interview process and then one
other step
i want you to try to get connected
to people that work in the company now
now you gotta
mature enough to handle that feedback
here's what i mean
just because i talk to one person and
they say something kind of negative
doesn't mean it's true i want to talk to
three to five to seven people
ideally connected to the sales type role
and we're gonna get real feedback we're
gonna look and see how do they treat
their customers what are their customer
review can we get vendor reviews this is
how we find out if a culture which means
shared behaviors is healthy and so i
want you to walk all the way through
stop letting fear
create a narrative right now you don't
know some things go get the answers to
those things and then the fear of the
unknown goes away and now you're going
to be able to make a good decision hey
why did you uh you said last month suck
because you took two weeks off why'd you
take two weeks off yeah
um we had sick babies i got sick um so
it was just like this cycle of people
getting sick in our household so your
kids were sick and you were sick is that
what you meant
yeah yeah yeah so it started off with it
doesn't matter where you work if you
don't work for two weeks
yeah 100 commission your month's gonna
suck
yeah that's irrelevant to this decision
both places your month would suck
yeah
so um
what would you do if you were working at
another position and your children were
sick
like that
in a regular job you just take personal
time off you'd use up your vacation time
and
yeah and they offer pto with this new
job
this current one i don't have they don't
have pto
why does pto matter if you're on 100
commission
you're not getting paid
if you don't work
regardless of pto
right there's not paid time off
you're not getting paid if you're not
selling something
right
so i mean they got you on some kind of a
base or they got a draw
um you know that's a good question that
i will ask the um
the person that i've been if you sell
real estate full time there is no paid
time off
because you're either selling real
estate or you're not
remember bailey that's 100 commission so
yeah dig into this like ken's saying and
let's find out what's really going on
here yeah it sounds like you have a uh
a third tier set of brands that are not
the prime brands and this bigger
company's got some better brands that
you can sell a lot better and sell a lot
more volume of and as long as they're
not gonna uh be all stuff shirt and make
it miserable to work there with the
toxic corporate crap
then it's probably the play to do but
you need to work through and prove that
to yourself that's right the quick
lesson here just for for bailey and the
rest of our listeners and viewers is
this the interview process is as much
for you as it is for the company they're
being interviewed too you have got to
have some confidence to ask these
questions you can do it in a way that
doesn't put the company on defensive but
you can ask really good questions that
allow you to get answers here's what's
going on and bailey you're normal you're
just like every other human being
there is any time we look at change
which we have to change to progress in
this case financially and professionally
there's going to be some unknowns the
quicker we can get the the knowns to
those unknowns now
we have the ability to discern and make
the right decisions
if they're convinced that it is better
right you're driving a thousand dollar
car and you get to change to a 20 000
car
you love change yeah right you know
right so you just got to be convinced
that the change is for the better change
that where there's a bunch of unknowns
the ambivalence will drive you bananas
oh yeah
absent of an answer our mind dave starts
to fill in the negative negative yeah
always negative yeah yeah if we don't
know what what's going on we
automatically assume bad stuff that's
right and uh and so the trick is in the
whole thing here bailey's just ken's
saying gather more information i love it
in a ramsey interview when our
team
that are is interviewing someone that
may be coming to work here
uh presents so much stuff about us that
someone opts out they go y'all are
whacked i don't want to work there
right because you weren't if they say
that they weren't going to fit in they
were going to be a negative culture ad
that's correct and we would have had to
fire them later and so it's much better
for them to self-select because we we
almost run them off yeah uh and we're
not trying and so we're being
interviewed too
you know when when you come into
interview here you're deciding if you
want to work here we're deciding if you
want your work here and so you got to
look at it that way it is a two-way
street and i
you know i i don't need to sell you on
working here but i'd i would love to
sell you on not working here
because if i can run you off before you
get in there and cause issues because
you're an idiot then that'd be a great
thing for us
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
dead free stage jessica is with us hi
jessica how are you hi dave how are you
doing better than i deserve welcome
where do you live uh i live in bourbon a
south of chicago oh welcome to nashville
and how much debt have you paid off 121
thousand dollars
how long did that take 28 months look at
you way to go kiddo and your range of
income during that time 70 to 90 000.
cool what do you do for a living i'm a
chemist for a pharmaceutical
manufacturer oh
look at you so what was the 121
000
um 2000 was my car loan and 119 000 was
student loans whoa wow whoa how long you
been out of school
i graduated in 2016. okay
and so two and a half years the last two
and a half years you've spent knocking
this out a little bit of a gap between
the time you graduate and the time you
really get into gear tell us your story
what happened yeah so i was almost three
years into paying
minimum payments on my student loans and
i was 25 years old living at my parents
house and i just got a new job and um i
felt like well what's next what can i do
next
and can i move out and um so i didn't
actually know my total debt amount at
that time because it was broken down
into several federal loans and i hadn't
added it up so i did that and i in my
head i thought it was 80 000 i had to be
around there but it was actually 119 000
and just the
realization that it's the oh crap moment
yeah oh crap because i knew i'd only
paid down about 20 something thousand on
the principal in almost three years
and so i'm just praying to god like can
you please give me contentment to
survive the next seven years because
i don't know how i'm going to do this
[Music]
and so actually one day i was talking
about it in my aunt she said
to me well why don't you pay it off
there's an option who thought that wow i
said i was yeah confused so i said you
don't make a dent in six figures of debt
and she said i know you you could do it
just listen to this radio show and it'll
click for you and you'll do it
i know you i'm not i don't even need to
explain it to you wow
left it just as at that
and i've got some nieces that are that
way yeah this one right here could do
that yeah yeah
she she apparently knew me better than i
knew myself
um so she had more confidence in you
than you had in yourself that's the
answer that's right so one day i had a
long drive and i just decided i have
curiosity to turn it on and there was a
debt-free screen a girl
near my age as well also single and
similar numbers as me oh
there it is
i felt like god just showed me my story
play out before it played out and
um i was so inspired by it i just knew
that my prayer for contentment was not
about to be answered
but i was happy about it
well it was just answered the answer was
no right
we're going to make you very discontent
until you get this straightened up
exactly i love it
uh dave i gotta tell this this is great
you asked for contentment yes and you
got conviction i did that's what you got
and then and then it's like oh watch out
yeah
because uh he knows her too there you go
i like it just like aunt knows her yeah
that's good good look at you okay so you
tore into it like a wildfire i did i did
um i
picked up some side hustles i
tutored high school students in
chemistry
and
it pays what i wanted to pay ah yes
because i was going to say as a parent
it's whatever she says yeah because
you're like help my kid with chemistry
yeah so what do you charge really what
is it how much is it
going up 280 an hour 80 an hour 50 an
hour i actually just do like 30 to 35
and i feel like
um it i've been you know growing into
that and increasing it but sometimes
that like
constant meeting helps if they can just
throw a couple dollars at it so i've
been kind of
figuring that out
but i you enjoy you enjoy coaching them
i absolutely do and i didn't realize how
much i would enjoy it but i started it
before even the pandemics
was around so oh then you became real
popular yes there were more students
than i could even take on and i wanted
to take them on
but for you
i just i was so happy to be able to help
students through the e-learning struggle
and to make an impact you're
amazing bucks a freaking hour
i love it and going up from here
oh man and knock out 121 000
in two and a half years
yeah two years and four months no less
yeah right my goal was to make it by age
30 but i just turned 28 right after or
right before i paid it off oh she be you
beat your goal by two years
[Laughter]
yep this is how it goes down right here
i love it amazing all right now that you
did it you're an expert
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is the budget is
everything it's important but it's also
the most freeing part of the journey
because
you get to set your pace yourself you
get to decide
am i going to buy this or am i going to
buy this or how much of each thing or
how much am i going to throw towards the
debt so it's all in your hands and it's
really empowering i felt when i started
budgeting that was my first step um i've
also gotten creative with saving money
and trying to buy anything i can used
my favorite blouse is like six dollars
from goodwill so ah look at you all
right
so did you stay home or did you move out
i ended up staying home
and um when i
paid my last payment on one paycheck i
actually put down a security deposit on
a townhouse of my own on the next
paycheck so
i was freed up to you know do what i
wanted yeah where i wanted okay so the
tremendous lesson here tremendous lesson
i'm gonna throw it back to you to keep
teaching because i thought you just
dropped a master class in something our
you know our colleague
uh rachel cruz talks about the budget
give you permission to spend you said it
empowered you in this journey because
you got to set your own pace
that has to be tremendously liberating
to say all right
because you went from telling your aunt
there's no way i can make a dent in six
figures of debt and now you're telling
us that the budgeting part of what we
teach
empowered you to set a pace that you
felt like you could get and ended up
going beyond that i want you to unpack
that a little bit more how did it
empower you
because
i would go back to that number and i had
my debt snowball you know and all
written out and i said okay well this is
the latest i'll pay it off and i knew
that if
my if i allowed my spending budget to be
outside of that or something to splurge
on that
that meant okay am i
am i comfortable with pushing it to the
next month oh that's good and i often
said no for that reason and i felt in
inside that i was
choosing what i wanted to choose
because you were because
you were you were in control of the
choice yeah exactly
this is where people happen to money
instead of money happening to them and
that's why people say the budget the
budget the budget and because it's
exactly why it's because you take you're
taking control and you're the boss of
the money and a lot of people spend
their whole life where the money is the
boss of them right and instead you're
going okay i have a choice and it's my
choice and i get to do what i want to do
and really the way you're saying it and
even your body language is i got no
guilt about either way but in this case
i choose to not do this thing so i can
get this other debt knocked out right
and two years early she comes in
debt-free way to go you're amazing thank
you you are an absolute warrior princess
you're amazing absolute rock star very
cool we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure you're
gonna be a millionaire before we know it
and also a copy of total money makeover
you can give that to someone that you
believe in
that doesn't believe in themselves yet
yeah i like that and a financial peace
university one year subscription you can
go through and join ramsey plus and go
through financial peace university get
the every dollar uh extended version of
the app and man ab enhanced all good
stuff all free we want to say thank you
you did a great job and what a great
great story you're an amazing young
woman thank you dave thank you ken i'm
so happy to be here jessica from chicago
121 000 paid off in 28 months making 70
to 90.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two
one i'm debt-free
yeah baby
yeah
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
one thing about humans being around
humans
we regulate to each other you find a
group of people that are inspired you
get in the midst of them you get
inspired
that's what happens at like your
favorite sports team when they're
actually winning and stuff
uh we all get fired up right and that's
what happens to smart conference when
you get like 8 000 people in one arena
and they want to be smarter you leave
well smarter because ken coleman spoke
and george campbell and rachel cruz and
christina ellis and dr john deloney and
me and my friends craig and amy groschel
pastors at life church are coming
they're gonna be speaking on marriage so
marriage money mental health uh
career we're gonna have it all covered
anything about your life we're gonna
talk about saturday october the 22nd in
dallas uh it's been three years since
we've gotten to do one of these wow
it'll be about 8 000 people there it's
about a quarter sold out already if you
want tickets they're only 39
get a great price on that that's an
incredible price for a full day event
you will leave exhausted and inspired i
promise you ramsay solutions dot com
slash events also check out the wealth
building events we're doing four cities
in the fall and uh you can get tickets
to those as well they are almost sold
out all of them
and people particularly concerned these
days
about how to build wealth in the middle
of a tornado
so and it's still possible it's still
even probable ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today paul is
with us paul's in cincinnati hey paul
how are you
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
yeah so
about a month or so ago i moved across
to a different state for a new job
ended up wiping out my small emergency
fund
for that
i'm slowly building it back up
and in the middle of that process
i expect it'll take about a year to do
that
and then within that i
realized i might need a new car within
two years or so
and i'm terrified of going into debt
again
good for that
i'm glad
hopefully you won't
hopefully you'll be terrified enough to
do it so what do you make of the new job
um it's 60 000. so where is it all going
shouldn't take you a year to build an
emergency fund
um say i'm only saving about uh 250. why
paycheck where's it all going
um
different things just you know i'm still
adjusting to new costs of living
my paycheck is only about
not only it's about sixteen
hundred dollars every two weeks
um
[Music]
but yeah it's pretty much just
have you got health insurance coming out
of your check
i do how much
um
about 60 or 70 i believe have you got
retirement coming out of your paycheck
yes it's about
three and a half stop it
okay you need to save an emergency fund
for your safe for retirement
i also think you have too much taxes
coming out of your check
because if you're making 60 that's 5 000
a year you're only getting home with 3
200. your taxes are not that high and
you didn't give me a you didn't give me
a health insurance number that was big
enough to call that cause that so you
still probably have too much being
withheld
paul what do you do for a living
i'm in journalism
okay
uh we are in one of the hottest side job
economies that we've ever seen before i
really think the way to juice this is if
you've got the time even if it's five
hours 10 hours 15 hours a week uh
deliver do whatever you've got to do
freelance right freelance do something
to make that emergency fund you can earn
that emergency fund very quickly in this
job economy yeah not not a year three
months yeah and then set yourself a goal
on the car and say all right i need ten
thousand dollars that's a thousand
dollars a month for ten months i gotta
do this
or whatever the goal is i just made that
up and then divide it out over how fast
you're going to do it
or i need twelve thousand dollars and
i'm gonna do it over two years that's
500 bucks a month i don't care but you
got to lay out the goal and then get to
it because here's what's killing you the
uh the unknown because you're not
working a systematized process the
unknown is scaring the p wadden out of
you that's what's terrifying you not the
debt
and so lay this out very succinctly very
detailed and then just start executing
on those numbers and you bust your butt
and you keep your dad gum spending down
you probably ought to get with your tax
person uh or uh just calculate your
taxes for the year and see if you're
having too much withheld i think you
probably got
a considerable too much i bet you're
holding 5000 bucks a year too much out
that's my guess 400 bucks a month
uh but i could be wrong we'll see you
run the numbers out and find out malcolm
is with us malcolm is in springfield
missouri hey malcolm how are you
i'm great uh what an honor i'm a little
nervous i hope i don't blow this you're
not gonna blow it we're here we're here
for you bro how can we help you okay
dave
i am 65 years old i've uh
you know been pretty frugal my wife and
i all of our lives never took big
vacations or anything
and tried to save we're i'm at a point
where
you know a year and a half from now or
in the next year i'll be at full
security retirement age
and
i'm really starting to worry now we've
i've got 401k and other retirements
uh everything i've got is a total of
about 1.2 million now that sounds oh my
god uh you know you're you're a blessed
guy and i truly am blessed however
we know a million dollars in what it was
10 years ago very true
frankly frankly i'm scared
i'm scared about retiring
um
what's your household income now
it has averaged about 250
uh over there you know over the last
several years way to go congratulations
you've had a great career yes okay so if
you retire and you have only social
security coming in
you're going to start to draw the income
at least off of this but that's not
going to produce 250 000 a year
and we don't need it
what do you need
uh
yes okay
what are the mutual mutual funds
invested in
well there's just
uh i usually an investment company and
you know and i i can't tell you i'll
stop by it exactly you don't need to
know you need to know that's part of
what's scaring you you don't know what's
going on
right you need to get with your guy on
the phone today
and say i'm scared you need to explain
to me what my money's invested in and
you need to be in good growth stock
mutual funds with long track records and
then ask the good what your track record
is on your mutual funds
and let's say you're in a series of
mutual funds properly invested and that
the last 30 years the track record has
been 11 on the portfolio that you hold
that would be a reasonably invested set
of mutual funds
okay
okay eleven percent of a million dollars
is 110 000.
okay
but within the climate that we're in
well yeah it's down 20 since the first
the year the big bad bears out right
but that's not the point the point is
over the next 20 years
unless the american economy collapses
which i am not predicting and i hope
you're not if you are you need to quit
watching the news
um that's the other thing about fear
that means you're watching too much news
turn the news off but the uh uh
because their job is to make you
terrified so you keep more fear porn but
the uh um anyway the the uh uh
over a period of time
you're gonna make an average of 11 or 12
percent that's a 70 80 year track record
on the stock market
okay so let's say you pull a hundred
thousand off but this year it didn't
make a hundred thousand so you dip down
into the principal some
next year you pull 100 000 off but it
made 150 000.
so you only pulled 100 off that other 50
goes back in to replenish the down year
you follow me as long as it averages
less than as long as you're taking out
less than its averaging the up and down
dipping into the principle and back out
it'll backfill itself over time does
that mathematically make sense to you
it does but and i know that's
historically accurate but have we ever
been in this kind of in
oh absolutely been a lot worse than this
a lot worse i'm not sure we've had any
dumber people in washington that's about
the dumbest group up there i've ever
seen but other than that
um i mean they're dumber than a rock the
whole it's like the island of misfit
toys up there but the uh um
but the uh other than that the actual
economy oh good lord go back to 1982 man
you're 65 i'm 61. don't you remember
that crap under carter oh my god gas
lines don't you remember interest rates
18
i mean that was a lot worse
this is a walk in a freaking park
average bear market is only 13 months
average time to recover from a bear
market is only 27 months
so a bear is is you know don't let the
bears scare you
he's the opportunity to buy cheap shares
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth through work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we talk about your
life your career
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
reid is with us reid is in san antonio
texas hi reid how are you howdy dave hey
ken thanks for taking my call i'm glad
to be on the show sure what's up
hey yeah so my wife and i got married
about nine months ago really excited and
we are thinking of buying a house and we
are adamant about not having any sort of
credit card or credit score now how do
we do that
okay you just have to have a mortgage
company that does what's called manual
underwriting
like churchill mortgage that sponsored
us here for
almost 30 years here on the ramsay show
they do manual underwriting manual
underwriting is what they used to do
before there was a fico score like when
i first got in the real estate business
okay right and that simply means that
they
in the old days now we wouldn't do it
exactly this way today but in the old
days we would mail the mortgage company
would mail
a vod
request to your bank a verification of
deposit to see if you have money in the
account to do your down payment they
would send a voe
to your employer a verification of
employment your employer would write
down and say yes he works here and
here's what he makes send it back to the
mortgage company that was all snail mail
in the old days right
and
but they actually went around and then
they they checked with your landlord and
they looked at your credit bureau report
and saw what was actually on the credit
bureau report what was being paid were
you paying the bills that you have on
time
and if you don't have any bills on the
credit bureau report they assumed you
were smart
um because you are uh and instead of
dumb not like the fico score says you're
dumb if you don't have any bills uh
because it's only a measure of how much
you play kissy face with the bank
so um the uh but that's how that's what
manual underwriting is it means they
manually actually have to verify that
the human being is capable of paying the
note
and um then you can get the mortgage and
it's the same exact rate
no more no less than a regular fico
score rate the difference is if you've
got a you know a
750 fico score a monkey can make that
loan they just look at the number and go
big number do it okay then there's
absolutely zero analysis
okay other than they depend on the
analysis that was created they created
the fico score to be their analysis
which is part of what caused the crash
in 2008 because we were loaning people
with high fico scores money who were
actually broke
and so we had a whole bunch of broke
people buying houses and it caused the
2008 crash that's not happening as much
now
but one thing fico has gone in and
worked on their algorithm because it
sucks
but um it's mathematically impalable but
anyway all that side issue from model
soapbox but yeah you can get a mortgage
just go to a mortgage company that
um
you know that does manual underwriting
ben is in norfolk virginia hey ben
what's up
hey how's it going dave thanks for
taking the call i appreciate it sure
what's up yeah
so my wife and i are be finishing up
baby step three probably january of 2023
i'm 37 i'll be retiring from the
military in five years
and right now we have
income enough to
put so much down on our house that we
can have it paid off in eight years but
i would not be able to do
the 15
of my gross income into retirement so i
was wondering what your thoughts were on
that uh even though i'd be gaining
a military pension in five years
if i could play catch up on retirement
later and just get the house paid off
super fast or do
um you know exactly for the baby steps
or in that situation what you would tell
people yeah i just like mustard butter
and ketchup um
the uh uh thanks for your service by the
way we appreciate you sure absolutely um
here's the good news in this whole story
you're actually thinking
most people don't bother we have a whole
population full of freaking zombies
that just go along and do whatever
amazon mastercard and apple tells them
to do
and then they google it and google tells
them they're smart
and uh none of this is true by the way
so um
the you're you're actually using
thinking skills way to go dude i'm so
proud of you i'm not i'm not being
facetious you really are the if you pay
keep paying attention like you're paying
attention you're going to be fine even
if you don't do it perfectly the way i
would do it okay you're going to be fine
because 90 of people winning is they pay
attention so
no i would not do that i would get out
of debt like you're planning um and in
january i'd start putting
as much as you can aside for a down
payment until you're ready to buy when
you buy put the house on a 15-year fixed
and start saving 15 percent of your
income towards retirement and um yes
you're gonna have the wonderful military
retirement which i'm very happy as a
taxpayer to pay you thank you for your
service
um one of the few things i actually
think we do well
uh
out of dc but yeah all all that to say
uh stay in order yeah follow the order
uh because you're gonna be in such good
shape what do you plan to do in
retirement from the military what's that
next chapter look like
yeah so i'm not 100 sure but i'm looking
at i finished my mba a few years ago and
so i'm looking into project management
uh maybe financial uh advising i'm not
sure yeah so the point is is everything
dave said amen amen amen but you uh by
doing it this way you're still gonna be
able to pay your house off because
you're gonna have that income uh
retirement income from the military but
you're gonna be making money and and
you're gonna have a wonderful ladder for
financial growth at a very young age so
you can do all of those things just
follow the order the baby steps and i
think in the long run you're going to be
glad you did well and here's the other
thing your income is not going to stay
static no
and your numbers you're running are
based on static income
so if you projected your income
increases out and then you know you're
guessing what you're going to do when
you leave the military but you keep
projecting that out you're probably
still paying the house off in eight
years yeah that's what i think but it
might be 10 but 10 is just fine uh you
know again because you're focusing
you're thinking you're thinking outside
of
the normative stupid butt stuff that
people do in this broke culture
and you know you're not just
clicking on prime all day long and then
wondering why you're broke
and um you know you're just being smart
so that makes all the difference in the
world you know ken i'm often asked in
these uh
interviews that i do and um and i don't
anyway it always comes up what's the
number one mistake people make with
money in america
and they always you know they figure i'm
gonna say credit card debt well that's
one up student loan debt that's one of
them uh leasing a car that's another one
whole life insurance that's another
there's too many to have one right but
but really what happens is that
the answer is is not paying attention
because no one sits down and goes hey i
want to be stupid right let's tell you
what stupid looks like but we just
wander along like a zombie
and come home with a new car
or you know you impulse a bass boat
oh my god
you know and so that this is what
happens people don't pay attention
anything that if you're gonna win at
anything winning is an intentional act
you want to win in your marriage you
have to intentionally embrace engage the
process of being married you want to
raise good kids it's not accidental it's
a lot of work because they're weird
you know i mean it's just a problem so
everything you went at you got to be
intentional
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america if you're looking to sell your
house right now there's a lot to think
about
it's crazy out there in the real estate
world
and people are buying houses prices are
not going down
we are seeing some individual markets
that are suffering from individual
maladies for instance
uh some of the markets in houston around
the energy and the oil problems that
biden has caused the energy world we're
seeing some of those prices go down but
overall the american real estate economy
is going up because there continues to
be a shortage of housing as compared to
the demand
if you're selling a house though you are
going to see with this bear market with
these increasing interest rates with us
heading into a recession you are going
to see a more normalized selling process
in most of my 40 years of fooling with
real estate i've seen about a 90-day
period of time to sell a house
i've never seen anything like the last
little bit where you would put a house
on the market and 82 people would make
an offer in seven hours
okay that is not normal for those of you
that have been living in that world it's
not a normal world and so that world
hopefully is gone it's not healthy it's
not good for the market it's crazy it's
weird so if you're gonna sell a house
you need a good real estate agent now to
walk you through the process and to work
with the buyers that are in the market
and there are still buyers in the market
to uh get them into the house it's not
amateur hour out there right yeah let me
ask you a question regarding this
because i think this is this is wise uh
to to unpack for folks is so we are
going to see now moving back to normalcy
is what i'm hearing you say on the
amount of time to sell but it doesn't
mean that you need to panic and lower
your price just because it's going to
take longer and that's why we want you
with a pro who can go hey relax yeah you
didn't sell it in five days doesn't mean
you need to drop it yeah i mean i i
talked to a guy on the air yesterday
he's had the house on the market for two
weeks and then got an offer and he's
panicking uh-huh yeah because
everybody's like oh god because we're
you know we're used to being a seller
right that you're putting a house on the
market is actually an auction
and that's that's not happening anymore
that's not going to happen in a six
percent interest rate environment um and
in the middle of a recession and a lot
of companies are laying off and so
uh
and you know it's just not gonna happen
but do we sell houses in that in that
kind of a market we have always
as a matter of fact that is a normal
market to sell houses in i've sold
houses in recession
and my whole life you know and as a real
estate person years past
um and we sold them in 1982 in a 17
interest rate wow environment and people
are buying houses not as many
as buy at three but it's not you know
and so yeah if you're gonna put your
house on the market you need to get a
really good agent and if you're gonna
buy a house you need to get a really
good agent it's a good time to do both
and uh there's a lot of people panicking
and freaking out there's a lot of fear
out there yeah um are you hearing people
say is it dumb dave to pay six percent
when six percent is if you look at
historical rates it's not like a crazy
rate oh you're talking about the
interest rate yeah like historically
it's not here's the thing
get the house right
if rates go down refinance there you go
okay well yeah i mean it but you know
you're not gonna the house is not gonna
go down right and so oh yeah house
prices are going to crash ramsay you
don't know what you're talking about
honey
i have this thing called perspective
i've got a long view
and let me tell you hope
comes from having long ball yeah
where you going to freak out mode and
your and your brain starts melting and
running out your ears it's because
you're thinking short that's right and
it you know and i understand even
intelligent people become afraid and
they lose their intelligence when they
become afraid
but um you're not looking at facts
you're not looking at data and you're
just freaking out because a lot of
people that are very very bright this is
their first this is their first downturn
that's right i mean 2008 was the last
one i think about a lot of young people
have never even seen a market with six
percent interest rate i don't even know
what it's like you know we never even
heard the word recession right
um or never um
never seen a slow real estate market a
medium real estate market it's always
been quite hot
because the last time listen 2007 we had
2.4
million new housing starts wow this year
we'll have 1.4
yeah we have a shortage of housing big
time and supply is just not there so
that's there's there's more buyers
chasing fewer sellers still that's
correct but just not at the auction
level i saw on the news today the ceo of
caldwell banker said that if there were
five to six million new homes built
right now that would get us at what he
would say a normal level of supply
exactly exactly so when there's that
much shortage
it's impossible right to deduce
in a logical mind that has a long track
record and is looking at data and is not
working on feelings that the housing
market's going to crash hey the guys
right there's a 5 million shortfall of
housing units the number of houses on
the market the last 3 years is 50 of the
number of houses on the market in two
thousand seven eight and nine right
fifty percent that's right
so here that you know just calm down
they get you a real estate agent though
go to ramseysolutions.com click on elp
and get get an agent to help you sell it
that knows what they're doing and here's
an idea
maybe an agent that has sold a bunch of
houses but maybe even an agent that has
been in the market a while
so they have perspective
because let me tell you
almost all fear
comes from no perspective here's what i
was thinking about you're driving down
the interstate today in nashville it's
like 94 freaking degrees right it's
hotter and snot out there
and it's it's also we got our little
humidity thing going so you can cut it
with a knife and put a block of humidity
in the back of the car it's unbelievable
right so you're driving down the
interstate tire blows
you're changing your tire
sweating like a pig oh yeah
and there's 18 wheelers blowing by you
about to kill you the whole time yeah
that's right thankful for the breeze
though this is what's known as fear yeah
this is a bad day
horrible
my heart rate is up
i have a john doloni call coming into
his show
for my mental illness that is developing
while i'm changing the tire here on the
side of the road yes i'm being
traumatized
right this is real all the things i mean
can you think about how pissed off
angst-filled anxiety-filled fear-based
you would be in the middle of that
you're you're physically threatened
you're hot it's horrible you bust your
knuckles on the stupid jack yeah you
know the whole thing right
in 10 years
do you even remember that no
so did it really change your life
it's not a great point not unless you
get hit by an 18-wheeler but other than
that it didn't change your life right
i mean it in 10 years did it really
change your life no it was a really
really
scary yes
anxiety filled moment in time but when
you pan back
10 years
you don't even remember it that's right
you don't even remember it you have to
think hard about what happened there and
even then it's almost a chuckle
you remember that time oh that's what it
is for me because of the futility that
would happen on the side of the road you
didn't even mention that well yeah i
didn't i mean me trying to change a tire
would probably be a great clip on
youtube just because of the sheer well
we could get a lot of hits on the camera
but because of ineptitude yeah it'd be a
lot look at this a lot of views but
now the point is think about all the bad
things in your life even something like
a cancer scare yeah i had a friend had a
cancer scare this year
and uh they came in and told him and
then they came back and go oh we missed
it
it's not there you know oh well that's
why they call it practicing medicine
so piss me off right but anyway you know
so but i mean but for about two three
weeks there we were all holding our
breath praying with this guy man right
and it was everything because it was
front and center because fear is in the
moment hope is in the long ball yeah
yeah that's right you don't find hope in
the moment very often most of the time
your hope comes in the long ball yeah
well perspective long-term perspective
and if you'll back up a little bit from
this and look at actual trends and data
over 20 or 50 years in housing and
interest rates
you cannot be so afraid i know some of
you are afraid and some of you get real
intellectual about your fear
but that doesn't make it not fear and it
doesn't make it right you're just wrong
the data is real clear on this
we're gonna do some more stuff on this
we're getting ready to announce a live
stream we're gonna do a big deal on the
real estate market and unpack some of
the things like that for
our audience to show you exactly what's
going on with this real estate market in
detail
with charts and graphs and stuff
yeah we'll let you know about that a
little bit later this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you're here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five regina is with us in
las vegas hi regina how are you
hi dave hi ken thanks for taking the
call sure what's up
well i need some perspective i
appreciate the last caller because i
think you you gave me a little bit on
that call but i'm looking for some more
um i'm currently on baby step two
um been four years gazelle intense
and i'm going to be
looking at a court date here tomorrow
that's going to end up increasing that
debt to about the tune of five thousand
dollars
um i have literally been
in zell intense for four years even
during covet and my gas stake is on
empty um i'm just not seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel
and i don't know if i can keep up the
pace that i've been doing i have three
jobs
and i'm just my guest tank is empty i'm
sorry so
i don't know if i'm i'm looking at a
bankruptcy or if i have to do something
not stupid
i'm sorry
um how much debt have you got not
counting tomorrow
10 grand and i literally was i was
coming for a debt free scream in october
[Music]
and what's your what's your income
my income is 45 a year i've upped it to
55 even during covid
but the problem i'm having is i end up
in court because all these extra
debts are attorney fees
and every time i go to court i don't
seem to be in good favor with the court
my child support is increased
so it's a very long
journey and i'm just tired
you pay child support
i do we have 50 50 custody and it
doesn't work out in my favor anytime i
go to court because he's a full-time
student making 10.50 an hour
okay and um what's the 25 000 tomorrow
tomorrow is the attorney's fees for the
last two years of litigation
you owe 25 000 to an attorney
yes sir
over child support
yes sir
it was because of covet it was extended
extended extended extended extended so
it's just well if he wasn't working
while it's extended why did the bill
keep going up
because my ex-husband made sure that the
bill kept going he kept putting things
in there and we kept having to respond
so you know as each response happened
it's that 250 an hour you know
so it just uh it's really spun out of
control
yeah you needed a new attorney
i'm pardon me you needed a new attorney
25 000 ago
i agree with you sir but unfortunately i
gave him a retainer and i had nothing
left in the tank after that that was my
emergency fund
yeah i know
i mean when you make 60 000 and you
spend 25 000 on child support that's not
in balance that's a
i totally agree with you sir i'm not
fussing at you i'm just crying with you
oh please fuss at me no you don't need
to be fussed at you you've gotten fussed
out enough um
you just gotta mask kiddo
so you owe the attorney's fees and the
attorney has sued you for the fees
yeah tomorrow is the day and we go to
the judge we've stayed off we've done
everything to try and
yeah you're going to lose because you
lose the money yeah exactly yeah yeah
i'm going to leave yeah well you owe the
money i mean it's not a it's not not
there's not really a thing to you know
he sucks as an attorney is not a defense
um right for the debt for the attorney
feast i mean you took them on so um
yes
and this guy
knows that you make sixty thousand
dollars a year
he represented me for two and a half
years and he knows that you don't have
any money
he knows that where does he think what
does he think this is going to
accomplish do we have any idea
i truly don't know i just guess he wants
to garnish my wages which is going to
basically leave me and my daughter in a
big deficit yeah it's going to change
our world yeah
so do you have uh i'm looking for
options i guess perspective
um
i would just tell him that we're either
gonna have to work something out
that is a tremendous discount and i'll
go scrape some money together and give
you a lump sum at a tremendous discount
or i'm going to help you to get zero
because that's called a chapter seven
bankruptcy
and and that's kind of what i did on my
own because i knew what i was up against
you told him that
yeah i basically said you know what i
have and you can go forward with this
but you know what's going to happen
and i basically you know laid it on to
him and he pushed he pushed the button
so i'm looking at this bankruptcy head
on and i just i want to know i'm doing
the right thing
trying to stay a step a step above and
a step ahead for my daughter's sake
um
well i i would i always tell folks if
you're going to file bankruptcy and i'm
i never recommend it it's a horrible
process to go through but if you're
going to
make sure you've tried every single
thing you can try
before you do it because i it is a
life-altering thing it's in the same
category as a divorce
it's something you want to avoid if
there's any way you can so you try
everything now you've tried almost
everything here but here's the thing he
even if he gets the judgment tomorrow
and he probably will
um
then he has to act on it and until he
actually does act on it
it just sits there
well he's he's pushed the motion to put
in a he's already filed the motion to
garnish my wages so there's not even a
judgment is there a judgment already
well we put a stay on it in my
understanding
correct
okay
well the day the garnishment you know
the day the garnishment hits that might
be the day that you make your decision
that you've done everything you can do
well the day the garnishment hits i'm
gonna have to move i mean i'm i'm that
tight no
no no no no no no if you file chapter
seven bankruptcy there's no garnishment
it goes away
understood okay so i'm saying if he if
he actually does do that
not just threatens it and so what we
want to be careful of is that we've
we've you know one more time i'll talk
to him one more time i'll say listen if
you do this and just say it out loud
just say
you're not getting a garnishment okay i
had this negotiation one time i was
negotiating for
a business guy that had a bank debt with
a local bank and i'm sitting with the
banker and the banker says we're going
to foreclose on the property which
obviously for a bankruptcy stops a
foreclosure
and um i said no you're not he goes oh
yeah i am yeah i am i said no
we're either going to there's two
options we're either going to work out
something as we sit here
with you guys and negotiate out some
kind of settlement
or the guy's going into a chapter 11
bankruptcy
or a 7 bankruptcy but you're not
foreclosing on the property i can keep
you from foreclosing on the property so
let's establish that you're not going to
foreclose
now
it's either because of a bankruptcy or
because we work something out so which
which one do you want to do it's your
choice
because well and then it comes well
we're going to foreclose i'm like dude
you're not real smart are you what i
just said was we're not go you're not
going to be allowed to foreclose your
federal court's going to stop you or
you're going to come to an agreement
today but foreclosure is not going to
occur that's the type of conversation i
would have with this attorney okay
there's not going to be a garnishment
either
i'm going to stop you with a chapter 7
and you're going to get zero in that
case or you and i work something out
and you know and then but that and those
type of
ultimatum discussions in a negotiation
are sometimes the last thing you can do
and you want to do everything you can do
to try to avoid this you've fought so
hard you've come so close and it would
be a bloody shame
for this one thing to take you down yeah
and practically speaking here whatever
the amount is i'm assuming dave that the
lawyer has shared what the amount is the
garnish would be and so we got a figure
so if he's going to get anything it's
that number or less that he agrees to
and then you look at okay can i keep
doing three three jobs and it doesn't
sound like she can do three more jobs i
mean three jobs much more right her tank
is empty as well our tank's empty
because she just keeps getting piled on
yeah but if she can push through and
manage to make that money a better
second job a better paying second job
that's that last resort to okay if i can
settle this with this guy and not go
into bankruptcy i'll give him five grand
cash and go borrow it
that's interesting yeah you know that's
what i'd cause you know really have 25
i'd rather five grand death 25 yeah
that's true but i mean we'll settle with
just one way or another here but try
some stuff like that regina because
sometimes these guys
they just you have to explain it to them
they don't they're smart sometimes
i mean dumb lawyers are everywhere
oh
lord of mercy i'm sorry honey hey hang
on we're gonna hook you up with one of
our coaches one of our financial coaches
see if they can walk you through this
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality open
phones at
825-5225
john is with us john is in atlanta hi
john welcome to the ramsey show
hey thank you so much for taking my call
i kind of got a unique
private question for you okay so um i've
listened to your show a lot um
and and
obviously
you teach on tithing which i've done
which
anybody out there if you're not tired
and you're making a huge mistake but
anyway i'm giving 10 to my local church
but i have living atlanta i have quite
the uh the commute to work and back so i
try to educate myself every morning and
listen to different sermons throughout
the morning and evening and i'm finding
myself listening to craig groschel
michael todd and i'm getting a lot of
information from them and really growing
from those two pastors amongst other
ones but those are the two major ones
that i listen to
and so now i'm kind of feeling like uh
not only should i be giving a portion of
that 10 to my local church but i'm
growing just as much if not more
listening to those pastors
should i be supporting those
churches also and
giving
a portion of that ten percent to to to
those
those churches or those pastors
i i really love your heart i appreciate
that and um
mike todd and craig groschel are both
personal friends craig's a good friend
of mine and um
i'm just emailing with him about an hour
and a half ago matter of fact but um
uh so i do kind of know what those guys
would tell you um and i think it's the
same thing i would tell you and i have
ken chime in here because he's a pk as
well okay what is the purpose
of the tithe
is it for you to buy a ticket
to a self-improvement christian seminar
no
okay it's not
the purpose of the tithe is to support
the work
of your local congregation it's
represented in the old testament
storehouse
and the storehouse
fed the widows and the orphans
and paid the priests
and that was the function of the
storehouse
and so you gave a tenth of your grain
to the storehouse the levites ran it in
the old testament
and a little bit of biblical history but
the point of it is not
to
pay
them for services rendered to you
the point of the tithe is to get a
rhythm of giving in your life and to
remind you each week
that you don't really own anything
you're just managing it all for god
and so
and there's a lot of grace around the
tithe so you can do whatever you want to
do god's not going to be mad at you for
sending mike todd and craig groeschel or
or whoever else you watch and both of
those are wonderful teachers by the way
world class
but the uh
the local church function is supported
by
you also
by your giving but that's not even the
reason for your giving the reason for
your giving is so you learn to be
generous
not so you purchase a ticket to a
self-improvement event and i'm i'm kind
of being i'm kind of being a little bit
smart ellie because you're like well
this is all where i'm growing from but
this isn't about your growth
okay i got you yeah well i was just
feeling like like if
you know part of the tithe in my opinion
obviously especially for the local
church is you're supporting that local
church so they can go out and do other
things with and and win
souls to christ these two these two
gentlemen are doing phenomenal jobs so i
felt like they are if i'm listening and
neither one of them are hurting for
money
yeah i understand yeah
neither neither church is in financial
trouble both churches are in excellent
financial condition and are winning
plenty of souls to christ
yeah okay john i would just i would just
add i think most pastors would uh agree
with dave and but they would also say
this is a preference not a principle
and so the preference is to support the
local body the local church however uh
the principle as dave says is to uh give
back what you've been given
uh a portion of
uh
and to the lord so let me say this
though i i think you gotta shift your
mindset from
um i should support those two ministries
to i could support them that's good and
i think that's the deal i think you
really love them i think you are but
that becomes an offering above the tithe
that is above and beyond tithes and
offerings there's another ministry over
here that does good work for god that's
right a good work for orphans good work
for whoever a good work for the unborn a
good work for you know and i want to
support that ministry that's an offering
over and above the tithe the tithe has a
different set of principles but now
having given you all this
nicky-nacky detail stuff i also want to
back way up and just say there's a
tremendous amount of grace over this
whole thing the whole principle is
god wants to make us over in his image
he's a giver he gave his only son
he's the ultimate in generosity
and so he's trying to make us in his
image and and the principle is to build
the giving muscle the generosity muscle
and always be building your generosity
muscle you hear me say that all the time
anyway but this is a uniquely christian
discussion we're having here for those
of you that are not people of faith but
um
but but that's the technical
answer from an evangelical christian
perspective and what has been taught for
hundreds of years is that the tithe is
modeled after the old testament
storehouse and that's why it goes to the
local church that's where the model came
from
uh and uh
you know there but you know bring all
your tithes
to the storehouse
and you know that's an old testament you
know direct quote so
uh but you know
and
you know then we can have all kinds of
other discussions but i don't think
you're going to hell if you don't tithe
but i do i can tell you this there's a
high correlation between people that are
generous and people who win at life and
money
it's very unusual to find someone
getting a divorce who's been tithing for
the entire time they've been married
because generous tends to make you less
selfish
and it's very unusual if you've got the
two of you as a as a couple have made a
decision to have a steady rhythm of
giving and your agree in agreement on
where that steady rhythm of giving is
going
called the tithe in this case it's also
very unusual that you're not in
agreement on most of the things
and it just it's it's an indication of
the health of the relationship in your
marriage and so
i i had an old pastor tell me one time
because i've been pastoring for 45 years
never had a cup of my church good
divorce that were tithers
and he was saying that as if the tithe
somehow is magical but i think the tithe
in and of itself is not it's the it's
the the principle as you said behind the
process
and the principle is generosity and a
steady rhythm of generosity that's a
wonderful question thank you john yeah
very thoughtful for letting us get back
on something that actually matters
that's really good that's a great great
question
yeah so
we'll back up one more step and because
i'll just take a second more on this and
ken because i love what you said there i
want to recap that uh because you do
want to pan back from these things i
in my early i became a christian as an
adult in my early days i became very
pharisetical very detailed about stuff
like where the tithe goes what counts on
the tithe how do you calculate it and
all that and i finally went oh wait a
minute
god doesn't really need my money
as if i was somehow singularly
supporting the kingdom that's hilarious
you know the arrogance of that is
unbelievable but pharisees are arrogant
and i was a young pharisee so um you
know but what i got to later was is the
tithe is not for god he doesn't need my
money
if he wanted me to take it and i'd be a
greasy spot it's all his god he don't
need my money and so
and really that church craig and todd
mike todd they're doing fine they don't
need your money but if you want to
support the work that they're doing
because it's incredible work and they're
not your local church then that would be
called an offering yes and i think that
there's something beautiful there too as
you're talking about generosity that if
you feel that you're receiving a
blessing yeah and you want to return
some of that blessing that is also
generosity as well to say you know what
i'm blessed by this i've felt some
impact you know what i want to give well
the widows might you know if you look at
that
well it's like living you know leaving a
tip that's exactly no sense i mean
there's an act of appreciation blessed
me tonight and the way you took care of
our table and i'm gonna be a blessing
back to you and yeah that's just it's
it's called class that's right you know
oh my gosh
selfish dad young people out there i
love john's question because he's not
he's anything but selfish he's just he's
that's right
and one other final funnel
god's not up there with a clipboard
looking at where you're giving and how
much it's the attitude it's the heart
condition and so you're in good shape
there don't don't worry about that just
give you're a wonderful young man very
cool
good stuff good stuff
ken coleman ramsey personality my
co-host this hour thanks to austin ben
zak andrew and kelly in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host and we'll be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they actually love and create real
amazing relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
cj's with us in denver hey cj what's up
hi ken um
i am in a pickle and a bit of a mess and
i was hoping you could offer some
insight some guys to help me get out
um here's a little bit of the facts i
lost my job two years ago during covet
and promptly went into hustling
70 hours a week delivering groceries
just to keep my head above water i was
in baby step four at the time so i just
paused everything um
nine months after that i just burnt out
i couldn't do it anymore i was in an
abusive relationship
and after a few months i ended up in the
hospital
you were in an abusive relationship
it's a long story how are you in an
abusive relationship when you were
working 90 hours a week you didn't have
time
yeah
family
has to do with family that is related to
me by blood not by
i guess okay okay
anyway
um i wound up in the hospital weighing
52 pounds i couldn't do anything
i spent the last six months rebuilding
myself and
now i'm in therapy for ptsd but i find
that i'm just quite
frozen when it comes to deciding what i
want to do as far as my career goes
next
okay wow what a ride trying to figure
out
what to do okay so let's before we get
into that real quick
so you you're no longer doing the 70
hours a week are you doing anything for
income at all right now
um
i wasn't for a while and then i started
delivering groceries again in a
different city just
to get a little bit of cash flow but i
noticed that
when i do that it pushes a lot of my
stress
okay um all right i just give things
that i don't want to do okay so again
before we start thinking about the
future i want to get you stable in the
now so what do you need to be making per
hour if we look back on their history of
you know what you made delivering
groceries what you need to make now what
what what do you need to make
gosh
um i'm trying to think i would say
ideally 18. 18 an hour okay so 18 and 20
bucks an hour is gonna keep you stable
is that correct before you go for high i
i'm i'm a little bit lost i got to catch
up with you jessica okay so you went in
the hospital and you weighed what 52.
52 pounds five two
five two
i didn't have anything left dave yeah
how old are you
i'll be 26 next month okay so what do
you weigh now
i don't know
well over a hundred good good okay so
we're going in the right direction
that's good and and how are you doing
with your mental wellness today
much better than i was six months ago
i'm still doing therapy three times a
week
um good
i think it really depends on
ptsd that you mentioned was from the
former toxic family member
yes okay all right and you're you've
obviously separated from that situation
so where are you living and how are you
living
so right now i need states um
and
you're what
and i have no contact with the family oh
you moved to states okay
i am living
with the roommate um
off of my emergency fund so you had a
little savings
i did okay how much is in your savings
right now i have 15 000 left okay so
you're living with roommates you're
still recovering
from uh
the whole
meltdown process for lack of a better
term good for you you're you're you're
you're getting victory i'm proud of you
and um
and you're not you're not creating any
income today so you're just literally
living on uh whatever you pull out of
savings in my understanding you're right
pretty much i make about 100 a week
by delivering groceries here and there
okay but but too much of that was
activating stress okay because i needed
to know that before i could understand
what kit work in was going to take you
from where you are
now how do we move from this place back
up into
a life of uh abundance for you and joy
right okay yeah yeah so first thing we
have to do is we don't need to be
delivering groceries anymore because
it's bringing up too many bad memories
so now we look for what can pay me 18 to
20 an hour
and i can get enough hours as i continue
with my therapist he's going to give me
some guidance here on on this
and and so we want to start there
so because we don't want to keep burning
through this emergency fund as soon as
possible if you can work 30 to 40 hours
a week if you're healthy enough
then i'm looking at things like target
walmart you know non-delivery type
situations where you've got some
stability community around you safe
environment and you can make that kind
of money they're paying 20 an hour
absolutely so we start there i want you
to get a short term what we call a day
job
and this is just getting you back to
safe
self-sustaining with your income now we
look long-term
so we go okay where do we ultimately
want to go
and there's a process where you've got
to start to
see things that maybe you've not seen
before and you do that by asking
questions like if if everything was uh
risk free if there were no risk and i
didn't have to train for anything i
didn't have to
to know if i was going to be good at it
just starting with
what would i want to do what kind of
work would bring me fulfillment and we
look at who are the people i want to
help
problem maybe that i want to solve or a
desire that i want to fulfill for
someone and then what are the solutions
to that so that's the starting process
for you so i'm just curious with all the
stuff you've been through i know you've
been through a tremendous amount i'm
just curious
uh what have you wondered about in some
of your deep dark hours you wish life
were better well what have you wondered
about doing if i could do this if i knew
i could be successful this i wonder what
this would be i'm just curious what pops
at the top of your mind as i was asking
you that
uh two things one i would love to work
overseas okay and two i want to help
people
kind of find their own way
um
out of abuse okay great now let's look
at the overseas thing very quickly
is there a type of work overseas or you
just love the idea of being in a
different country is there some type of
people group or type of work overseas
that pops in your mind
um
definitely more
third world work okay
for the least of people that maybe don't
have much of a shot you can help them
with a better life so we've got
something to work with here okay so let
me repeat your homework okay and i'm
going to give you a couple of resources
here's what i want you to do
overseas people who maybe
unfortunate circumstances in their life
or maybe poverty that's one group than
here in the united states people that
have gone through abuse
who's helping those people
what's the best way to help them what
appeals to me
and who's doing it how do you get there
what does it cost how long will it take
this is looking out into the future now
all of a sudden you go oh there is a way
there are a couple of mountaintops and
as you continue to learn more with your
head
your heart will eventually select
in those areas hang on the line we're
going to give you the get clear career
assessment which is a 20-minute tool or
really answer a lot of those questions
and we'll give you my best-selling book
from paycheck to purpose which is the
path
to get you up that mountain once you
select it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america let me ask
you a question when you think of a
millionaire what kind of job do you
picture them having
some kind of high-powered executive
position like a vp a ceo
well here's the thing only 15 percent of
millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is the top five careers
for millionaires in america are
engineer
accountant
teacher
manager
and attorney
docs didn't even make the top five
medical doctors are number six
that's why just one of those that's just
one of the surprising things we found
when we conducted the largest study of
millionaires ever done
we talked to ten thousand millionaires
to find out who they really are and how
they got there did they inherit it
or were they famous or do they make two
million dollars a year our study also
made it clear that to become a
millionaire you've got to invest wisely
what we discovered was was that 89 of
millionaires did not become millionaires
because of inheritance 9 out of 10.
9 out of 10 millionaires became a
millionaire starting from basically
nothing
and so hey they invested steadily they
got their house paid off that was the
typical scenario
and we call them baby steps millionaires
you want to join the bunch well you need
to get with a good investment advisor i
was just talking to one at the break as
a matter of fact go to
ramseysolutions.com smart vester start
really building wealth today you can
find a smart vester pro in your area
that'll walk with you teach you help you
do the stuff the way we teach here on
the air and it'll work for you
this
is how it's done ramsay solutions.com
smart vester mitch is in cincinnati hi
mitch welcome to the ramsey show
hello dave thanks for having me
appreciate you very much and uh so my my
general question and then i can give you
any sort of specific details is um
because like interest rates are going up
with the announcement today that the
fed's increasing what 75 basis points or
something like that
um i have an assumable i have a va loan
and since it's assumable and
values of homes just continue to
seemingly skyrocket
i wanted to get your opinion if it would
be
something i should look into and
potentially selling my home to
pay off
some of like
the non-mortgage debt that i have
and then maybe i don't know after a year
or so
maybe move into a different house
whenever the mortgage would be the only
thing of debt i'd have yeah
it's not my preference do you like the
house
um
the house in general yeah i would i
enjoy it um what started this
conversation was actually my wife
doesn't like the backyard she doesn't
like the backyard okay okay it looks
like a cliff and we have a one and a
half year old so okay you can't really
play too much outside yeah and how much
debt do you have
so not counting non-mortgage debt um i
would say approximately 60 from her
vehicle my student loans and then
um two credit cards i got
and what's your household income
um
i would say
after taxes i think it's about 52.
what do you owe on her vehicle
um
i approximate at about 30.
so it's 30 for a vehicle 20 for my loans
and then um
maybe south of 10 for the two credit
cards okay
well let me tell you one of the things
we found with millionaires as we studied
them
they did not have an inordinate amount
of their
life
dollars invested in things that go down
in value
when you make sixty thousand dollars a
year and you have a thirty thousand
dollar car it's hard to win
because the car is going down in value
you have a car you can't afford
so we're going from getting mama a new
backyard to now selling her car this is
not a good conversation for her
[Laughter]
yeah i think i think we need to probably
get you get you a hotel room
we'll go move into the in-laws right
yeah
no no i i listen i i think you guys have
got to address your overall management
of money and spending and get yourself
out of debt before you start talking
about moving houses instead of using the
house to bail you out and then not be a
homeowner you're selling a thing that
goes up in value
meanwhile you're sitting on a thing you
can't afford that's going down in value
so you know i really wouldn't sell the
house right now i'd really concentrate
on getting out of debt
and if i woke up in your shoes i would
get into financial peace university i
would sell the car
uh with her on board of course i'm not
gonna go don't go in and announce to
your wife you're selling her car because
dave ramsey said that's not gonna make
you or me popular okay nor does it nor
is it going to work
so um you need to go in and start
talking about the future and how we get
into a better house and how we learn to
live on less than we make and that our
income is not big enough to support the
debts that we've taken on and we've got
to do something about this debt and
let's talk about the debt that that that
and let's get in this class i'll give
you financial peace university for a
year hold on austin i'll pick up and get
you signed up for that the two of you
start watching that together and she may
come up with the idea to sell her car
because it needs to go away
uh it was a bad purchase
and you need to quit buying things
because you want them when you can't
afford them
and um that's what you're getting ready
to do with the next house too
yeah and let's just be very clear for a
second here because when you know dave
and i've been married a long time dave
longer than me obviously but i mean when
mama is worried about the backyard and
the kid and the cliff that is also a
significant thing he has to overcome i
mean the car's hard enough dave but now
this is a marriage conversation to go
let's not get too worked up over this is
the kid really gonna wander out i mean
how dangerous is it because that's a
fear thing that's a fear factor yeah
yeah i mean it's okay to move but um
moving in order to clear the debt and
not owning a house in a market where the
prices are still going up is not
no i'm not going to recommend that yeah
not right now
not while you have still gonna address
the underlying issues right bad idea
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free free samples free shipping new
promos all the time always use the promo
code ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from hank in
iowa i'm 21 and i currently work the
night shift in a warehouse earning 16.50
an hour i do get benefits with that i'm
also scheduled to take my real estate
license test next next week and have a
second job in property management making
16 an hour without benefits both are
full-time but the job with the property
management
would be a long-term company that would
allow me to pursue my real estate career
should i keep doing both jobs or would
it be too much to handle
no i don't know how you keep that up
i know you're 21
but 21 year olds need to sleep as well
and look like you got a nighttime great
graveyard shift uh no i would be going
long term making decisions for the long
term what puts me on the right ladder
to climb where i want to go and it's the
property management company that allows
you to start moving towards the real
estate career which is the ultimate goal
anyway so that would be the move i would
make yeah and let me add this to you
hank okay
um
very seldom like i i'll just tell you
less than five percent of the time
should you make a career decision
based on benefits yes
or based on 50 cents an hour
either one
you should make career decisions based
on
um
being in what ken calls your sweet spot
you should make career decisions based
on where it's going to take you in the
long
term where you're going to be 10 years
from today you're 21 where you're going
to be when you're 31 or you can be in
your 41
and the warehouse job doesn't fit in any
of those
and don't make career decisions based on
uh
air quotes
around security this is a secure job
i laugh at your security
let me tell you where security comes
from
a big old freaking pile of money
it comes from that and and faith in god
it does not come from corporate america
it does not come from i make 60 of what
my peers make but i work for the
government and they'll always pay me
well sure they'll always pay you your
job sucks
you know
no
security is not based on whether they're
gonna actually give you a check every
week security is based on you being in
the zone baby
and and going and living your best
possible big life and that'll buy
benefits and that'll buy security
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the free stage tim is with
us hey tim how are you hey dave hey ken
great to be here absolutely welcome
where do you live well i'm originally
from canton ohio but now that i'm on
baby step seven i'm on a cross-country
roads trip of all 50 states all right
that's free i love it very good for you
and how much have you paid off 95 000
very cool and uh how long did this take
just over three and a half years okay
cool and your range of income during
that time started out at 45 000 now i'm
over six figures okay good for you good
what do you do for a living i'm a
project manager for an event technology
company
and you can just do that from the road
yeah i work from home my
manager and director are fine with it
and so far i've actually just been
promoted so now i'm making over six
figures on the road so way to go very
cool i'm pumped very cool so the 95 000
was what kind of debt
it was a mixture of my house
student loans car and a
credit card okay so my aunt gave me a
very good deal on her house when she
went to go live with her grandbabies my
aunt bev
so i started on my journey with in 2018
i had part of my student loans uh paid
off then i had a credit card and i had
just bought a new car
and my journey actually i did listen to
my broke brother-in-law dave so he
introduced me to you
i watched your youtube channel and i
submitted to the plan wrote a check paid
off the car
uh and then just did the baby step baby
baby step two and i just kept going and
paid off my house since my aunt gave me
a good deal okay so the house is still
sitting there while you travel no i
flipped it actually i took advantage of
the hot market and i flipped the house i
did some cosmetic updates and was able
to double my money so good for you now
i'm just cash flowing the road trip
month by month uh traveling the country
having a blast i love it good for you
man that sounds fun it really it does
i'm just curious uh was this an idea
that you had at any point in the debt
free journey or is this something that
came to you once you paid off that last
debt and your perspective changed so i
paid my house off this past december and
on october i was doing the math and
figured out that it was going to happen
and i said what am i going to do next i
knew i didn't want to stay in the area
it wasn't a house i wanted to be in
forever i bought it with intention of it
being my fresh start you know flipping
it getting as much money out as out of
it as possible i worked hard to pay it
off so that i could use the full money
to do whatever i wanted next
i think i want to get into real estate
long term as investments i think i also
want to own a business someday of my own
so
um no
the road trip wasn't exactly
in the plans but in october i said you
know what i knew i wanted to sell the
house take advantage of the market and
then i just went with it and so
uh i sold the house january was out by
march and have been on the road ever
since i love it i love it very cool so
the goal is see all 50 you said
eventually yes i know i can't drive to
hawaii or probably alaska but those will
be my last hurrahs okay
fun man that's awesomeness yeah it's
been great thank you so much for all
that you guys do because uh i was able
to see that and submit to the plan years
ago and i just love being here and
seeing everybody yeah great cool so
three and a half years you're putting
through this what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
submit to the plan i mean uh you guys
have put the work in to tell us exactly
what to do so just submit and and follow
through it um
yeah
what does that mean i i know what it
means but submit what did that mean to
you what was submission like cause
that's that's a little different for
everyone i was in the co mine was a lot
of my time was during covet so i got
furloughed um
and that almost threw me off the plan
but i knew that i had my ducks in order
you know i knew i had an emergency fund
already i was on baby step uh six by the
time i was uh furloughed so i was just
cash flowing and i just said all right i
have to slow down the cash flow a little
bit on the house i'll be fine i had my
emergency fund
so uh throughout kovid i changed jobs a
couple times because i just i wasn't
it coveted really rocked my world as far
as career-wise my friend dawn finally
called me up after i had changed jobs
twice and offered me my dream job of
being a project manager and i ended up
doubling my income along the way
so i started out at 45 then i made 90.
now i'm up to over 100 and within the
last couple years so
i did most of the baby steps on 45 000.
so now that i've got double that i'm
like oh stars in the eyes i'm just so
excited and no payments
no
and i turned 30 in august so all of this
is done before i'm 30 and now i am just
living and giving like no one else i
just have this intense joy whenever i
see someone you know on the road needing
money i stop and give them whatever i've
got in my wallet
which isn't always a lot i use my debit
card for most everything but
yeah i'm just i'm living and giving like
no one else and i've just felt this
intense joy and my family and friends
can see it and they keep asking me what
happened and i said i'm following dave
dave ramsey's plan yeah the way to go
man i'm so proud of him
very very cool so who are your biggest
cheerleaders
well my sister uh carrie she uh married
to the brother-in-law married to the
broke right well not any longer married
to the brother i'm kidding you said that
i did well it's funny because i heard
that from you and i said you know what i
did follow my broke brother-in-law's
plan you know he got me into it so
yeah um so i wrote a check so your
sister was a uh your biggest cheerleader
and who else uh yeah my friends and
family you know um
i i really did a lot of this on my own i
submitted to it uh
and even during baby step two i was you
know i was still able to do things with
my friends because i had my budget in
order i had some play money that i that
i gave myself you know to be able to do
things but not like go over be able to
go out and have like one drink with
friends at times or or anything like
that not just go above so
um
my friends didn't look at me crazy but
now they're looking at me crazy like how
are you able to afford to do this i said
well
i've submitted to the plan
so so as a project manager that's what
that means to you you're a systems guy i
am yeah
you find a system that works you execute
the system why change it yeah absolutely
this is a proven process don't mess with
it submit to it do it the way you know
this is how you build a house follow
these three steps build a house you know
that's how you get a job follow these
six steps seven steps how you get a job
there's a system there's a process
that's proven and find that
uh from someone that again that's proven
and if you're managing a project that's
how you manage projects and so for you
submitting to that just simply means
agreeing that that's the truth and then
doing it yeah i mean you you hooked me
when you were talking about the 19 year
old
and you're all like it would all be
great if we were all 19 and i was
looking at myself at 24 and i said well
i'm not that far away let's get this
let's get my act together you know and
so i started and um yeah three and a
half years later
we're traveling the nation excellent
very cool man i'm proud of you thanks so
much very very good work we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
awesome ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth you are going to
too yes sir copy a total money makeover
you can give that away on your travels
as well you'll run into somebody that
wants to hear this story and a copy of
we're also going to sign you up for a
year of financial peace university
and uh thank you if you don't want to do
it or you've already done it then you
can give that away as well so we've
given you plenty of things to
take you on the next part of your
journey and also make sure that um your
financial journey you've got another
journey you're doing but uh your
financial journey and make sure that
you've got the way to do it and make
sure you got some stuff to help other
people with so well done tim thank you
so much
tim and clanton know how canton ohio
used to be anyway 95 that now he's just
about
to walk about
95 000 paid off in three and a half
years making 45 to 100. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
you know ken the uh that's just a great
story and you you caught on to him
saying submit a lot of yeah
um but in the process of getting a job
you've laid out the seven clear
steps you submit to that or you push
against it and you get to submit to it
anyway that's right you know we lay out
the seven baby steps to uh you know to
become not only debt free but then
become a baby steps billionaire and
outrageously generous and almost 10
million people and over 10 million
people have gone through those between
financial peace university and the total
money makeover at this stage so he's
right it's a proven
process but anything you're working on
if you're doing weight loss and you know
you do a proven process and here's a
proven process here's some things that
here's things that are proven that don't
work in relationships there's things
that are proven that don't work in your
mental health
and you know here's things that do work
called boundaries and that kind of stuff
so submitting yourself to
the law of gravity
to proven
principles
is ideal for creating a successful life
yeah i mean it's the idea here that hey
this will work
if
i give over control of my emotions and i
give discipline to the path and if i do
this i win that's the idea and it works
over and over and over again this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 10 31
do not be afraid
you are worth more than many sparrows
[Music]
sarah blakely billionaire woman founder
of spanx
i think failure is nothing more than
life's way of nudging you that you are
off course
it's course correction that's what it is
i agree
uh people in the technology feel fail
for a living they call it iteration
yeah
our good friend john maxwell wrote a
book entitled sometimes you win
sometimes you learn yeah which is a
great perspective on failure you know
there's no progress without failure he
writes a book a week another one another
one was called failing forward that's
right that's right yeah
jessica's in syracuse new york hi
jessica how are you
good how are you thank you so much for
taking my call sure how can i help
so uh long time listener first time
caller that was from my husband
so
i got that
to that end i know that you generally
say that you know emergency funds are
not there to build you wealth obviously
they're there for your security good so
with that being said how much effort
would you put into chasing a better rate
almost our um
our emergency fund and our long-term
savings has been
in a high-yield account you know before
the pandemic it was at like two and a
quarter it dropped way down to like 0.5
and it's sitting at about 0.85 right now
and out of curiosity i jumped on the
internet today to see what's out there
and i saw another one sitting up at one
point five so that's fine moving over
there if you will double what we've got
yeah that's fine i mean how much is in
your emergency fund
uh the emergency fund is ten thousand
then we've got our automotive sitting in
there as well so maybe another two
thousand okay so one percent of 10 000
is what
oh goodness i'm an accountant you're
going to ask me
well 10 10 of 10 000 is one thousand one
percent is a hundred dollars
okay so moving from a half to one and a
half over a period of a year you made a
hundred dollars
yes i'm not a shirt sticking yeah right
yeah so it's okay i mean a hundred
dollars is nice you can go at the dinner
nice place on that well a reasonably
nice place
and um but but it's not it's not going
to change your life
right even over a period of decades it's
not going to change your life so yeah
but what does change your life is having
the emergency fund
as an insurance policy when life happens
that keeps you from cashing out things
that are growing at a rate that does
change your life so if you don't cash
out your 401k to fix your transmission
because you have an emergency fund
that is a lot more than a hundred
dollars
so your original point is what i would
refer back to but again
so would i spend 500 hours to get a
hundred dollars no i don't think i would
uh would i surf the internet every so
often and see if i can get a high yield
thing that makes me an extra 100 yeah i
might a little bit
i've got a bunch of cash laying in the
company here in our retained earnings
business version of emergency fund and
we spend some time on that trying to you
know uh figure out how we can park that
in some kind of float account so it's
not all just sitting and checking
you know it's just because it's a lot of
money and um but even then it's not its
purpose is not to grow wealth for the
company its purpose is to protect the
things that do grow wealth for the
company and so just have to kind of
balance that out so yeah i'll spend some
effort on it but i'm certainly not going
to major in minors that's what it
amounts to john's with us in new york
city hey john welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for having me on how are you
better than i deserve what's up
yeah so my grandparents left me with
about two hundred thousand dollars
i'm not sure what to do with it i don't
have any debt
landlording
and i don't wanna buy a house for myself
um but i do wanna do remote landlording
but i was researching and some people
said that it's a nightmare and and
property managers aren't that good um
yeah uh okay how old are you
26. what do you do for a living
i'm a software developer good for you
okay
all right and you're not you're a single
guy
yep okay and you don't want to buy a
house why
um i uh
i don't like the maintenance the lawn
mowing all that stuff the cleaning
mm-hmm
okay that's fair
you like the freedom of not not being um
anchored down to that house yeah
they they are they are a problem i got a
dead dadgum project at one of mine right
now it just drives me crazy there's
always i told sharon the more more stuff
you own the more repairman you have to
know so i kind of i kind of go along
with you john i like it
um especially your stage of life and
there's no rush for you to buy something
um so i'm sorry about your grandparents
when did they pass
a few weeks ago whoa
just the other day
both of them at one time
uh it happened between it happened with
a few days within a few days yeah my
grandma
had a heart attack after my grandma my
grandpa passed so oh my goodness
oh man i'm so sorry
were you close to him
yeah pretty close that's my reason for
staying in in new york city even though
it's pretty expensive because i i would
say i love my family and want to be
close to him
yeah okay
all right um no i would not do remote
landlording i think that's a bad idea
if you're not willing to cut your own
grass then i don't you don't need to be
doing landlording
uh not that you have to cut the grass
there but it just tells me you don't
like hassling dude you can already sign
up for a bunch of hassles so
that sounds like some kind of get
get-rich-quick crappy site you were on
or something there don't fool with that
if i were in your shoes i'll tell you
what i would do and it's very boring
i would park the money in a mutual fund
for right now or a couple of three
mutual funds
and just forget it forget that it's
there
and just let it grow
and then uh a little further down the
road if you decide you want to buy a
property or maybe you're getting married
and you want she wants you to buy a
property or you know that kind of stuff
is happening then you know that's the
kind of stuff i you know but but for
right now it might be three years before
you do anything with it and the stock
market's way down right now so it's on
sale
so if i woke up in your shoes and i had
an extra 200 that i didn't really have
anything to do with i first thing i do
is try to put it someplace where i keep
my hands off of it not spend it right
and then the second thing i would do is
um put it someplace where i couldn't
spend it
yeah yeah you know
having said that though you might want
to earmark a little bit of it for fun
and pull it out and go do something fun
if you got any ideas on that
yeah yeah probably uh probably travel to
europe or something
so what's that cost um having to look at
okay
yeah i mean budget five grand or
something or ten grand or something and
go do that and the rest of it sit down
go to ramseysolutions.com click on smart
investor you can sit down with smart
vista pro
and begin your
education on investing
begin learning from an advisor you don't
take an advisor's advice you don't take
dave's advice
you sit down and you are other than the
piece of advice this is you're supposed
to learn about something before you
invest in it
and it puts him in a pretty good
position it really does you know i
beyond doing something fun with it i'd
also just let your heart wander a little
bit and uh you know do something good
with it don't have to be huge don't you
feel any pressure to do that but
something good something good with that
money you know some kind of generosity
generosity that's not a bad way to kind
of start
moving into this phase because it uh
it'll really set something in place
something special in your heart this is
something your grandparents did for you
it's a way of honoring them but again i
don't want you to feel any pressure to
do that or on a large scale but just do
something good do something fun i like
that combination then do something smart
yeah yeah maybe you know if you put five
percent of fun and five percent to
generosity that'd leave you on ninety
percent yeah to it or something like
that no no pressure but zero it's always
good to try to do those three things
have some fun with the money be generous
with the money and invest the money in
this case the vast majority of it i
think i'd be investing yeah um
and
i would limit the fund but i think i
would do something there
um
and
you know when you get to 30 years old or
35 years old and you look back and
whatever you've ended up doing with this
money it needs to do it needs to be
something that would have caused your
grandma grandpa to smile yes
and then you've honored their memory
because they had common sense they were
obviously good with money they had some
money they left their grandson
200 grand that's pretty incredible
so ken coleman good show today thanks
for having me good work in the booth
kelly and andrew and zach and ben and
austin good job you guys i'm dave ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you